okay for people who are joining our live
stream this is meeting to talk about
features of whorfin language which have
been considered experimental but which
we are considering D experimental izing
for the next version so let's start off
with anatomy what is this about let's
see should I be running 11.3 or should
be running 1200 11.3 is probably better
I haven't tried it in 12 so I don't know
what the status of 12 is right now okay
all right so what let me let me just get
the basic thing that we're looking at
here so this is anatomy plot 3d of for
example left thumb or something so well
these medical things okay that's a kind
of weird polygon at the top there you
can use your power plot beans if you
want a different look to it
and right how do i okay so now the
question is how do we put skin on here
is that one of the questions all right
we have an option called skin style that
will automatically try to do and pull it
in and I think that how would we put
that into an Anatomy plot 3d well you
could say skin style goes to automatic
for example that's probably the simplest
form I see so in here okay
9
two layers at levels of skin it's best
the model is it's thick you know the
skin has a thickness but it's not a
volumetric thing it's surface models I
see so those are two okay fair enough
um okay that's cool all right so now
what what's the first question this
thing the main issue was that I think
that skin style was considered to be too
general of a name if it was gonna be a
global system option because I think you
had concerns that might somebody might
think there pertains to something else
so I think we were late it's pretty
weird that it's actually the skin style
of skin uncommon cool well I think the
simplest suggesting that I have was we
just put Anatomy in front of it
anatomical skin style or Anatomy skin
stone that way it matches the function
name Anatomy plot 3d and it also matches
anatomy form which is the three
functions or the symbols that are in
question for the experimental izing
anatomical skin style or Anatomy would
be consistent with what we'd use for the
other symbols I don't think it's really
right though I think it's really weird
and mattum is skin just seems weird what
do other people think about anatomical
skin style and we don't what do you mean
what's that it's clear in both cases
what this meant which either skin or
anatomical skin yeah I think it's both
well I mean skin scars perfectly clear
in context in context out of context
it's utterly obscure unless we think
that somewhat bizarrely and something
they were abusive anything that we
actually will use this for some kind of
image 3d skins or something like this I
briefly spoke with Charles to see if
they had any cut you know ideas about
ever using any symbols with it you know
the term skin and in at least P saw that
they didn't have any plans of doing that
well that's because they're not thinking
about skinning you know geometries and
stuff like this right I mean
Michael what do you think about
anatomical skin style
I'm pretty fine with it all right let's
go with it what's that what's the
question here about render render so you
had tried an input that you basically
had drawn the left foot and the third
left met or the left third metatarsal
and you made the left foot you did style
of opacity 0.3 and you did the third
left metatarsal as red and you could
yeah let's go ahead and reconstruct it I
guess right okay so what you're saying
is a style left
yep opacity point three and then it was
style what was it
left foot left foot no the second one is
one of the metatarsals oh I'm sorry all
right right right right you're right
young enough of my foot - that's a man
and you did that like comma red okay
look in the original example they were
reversed in order but I don't know if
that matters or not Bret do you have any
other uses for skin so to speak I don't
think so I mean I think if I was doing
geometry it'd be more likely that I'd be
referring to a surface or something okay
well this this this this worked because
it colored the bone red as you asked but
if you reverse the order
you know nice okay but if you reverse
the order you don't and we looked into
it and it turns out what it is is we're
getting lucky in this case what you've
essentially done is you've actually
asked for the same Ida you render your
eyes twice yeah and it's a coplanar
polygon issue so this is why Anatomy
form is useful it allows you to change
things in place rather than pulling it
in twice so that's that's one reason
Anatomy form exists so that you can
style things that are already there what
do you mean so so how do you do okay so
wait a minute so this
this is basically rendering the thing
twice right correct
will it always work if I put it second I
don't know if I can guarantee that I
think that's a front-end thing yeah
because those polygons are basically
being rendered in the same place and
it's anybody's guess which one comes out
on top yeah great
um okay so what's the official way to do
this well there's two ways like I said
Anatomy form is the proper way to do it
because that's that allows you to modify
things in place so you don't pull it in
twice what do you mean by in place so I
mean you're saying well I'll just do the
left foot and get rid of the style just
do left foot yeah but just tell me what
I'm gonna be doing okay and then in
front of left foot put Anatomy form oh
boy is this not a rapper is this like
edge form no you're not you're not doing
Anatomy form of left foot you're doing
something no I'm saying that right it's
like edge form which I don't really like
very much I mean I I think the modern
form of that is is more the style rapper
is there a way of doing edge form in a
style rapper fashion I wouldn't know
well maybe you put it inside the style I
mean the fact is that this sequential
directives type thing
I just view as being what wait a minute
why would this not then if I say comma
red comma that why doesn't that work
why do I need the anatomy form now the
the anatomy forms not complete the
anatomy form you say which things you
want to style so you typically give it a
rule so you're inside of anatomy form
you say left third metatarsal bone goes
to red so here what am i doing anatomy
if I won't copy or get your left third
metatarsal bone cut it okay why isn't
that rough coming up why isn't why isn't
my is anatomy form not documented so yes
yes it's documented okay then why is the
rough that why is that
ruff not coming up there I'm moving the
mouse there why is that rough not coming
up see that is it coming up on opacity
yep
that is weird that's coming up on
Anatomy plot 3d it works for me can you
click out of anatomy form that's
interesting it's a bug live and in
person sigh okay and you're an 11-3
right yes okay no I hit I just graphics
directive so this is saying what should
be styled how right if you were to
choose so it on its own does nothing or
does it it doesn't value but it but it
does it's like edge form correctly but
it's not doing something like style I'm
a making sense where right so that would
do nothing correct
but start also some only are
context-sensitive what do you mean I
mean if I'm saying style
you know disk comma read/write I much
prefer that form to the older you know
sequential directives form Steven yeah
try it with Anatomy form inside the
style okay so if I say style of left arm
oops
, this thing here hello what's it doing
going through an analyzing structure
that worked okay so does that also work
well so yeah so if I were to say do you
yet have um if I'm in version 12 would I
yet have the polyhedron stuff well okay
let's just say polyhedron data if I am
can I do that for face form as well to
put it inside a style probably if one
can we should document that I mean this
let's see whether this just works I just
think it's a much better way to do this
I mean Brett yes you disagree with me
about about there I mean I tend to use
the sequential form yeah I know what one
does it's a sloppy thing to do and there
John's a big proponent of the sequential
form and not style but which John John
volts why I would have thought he would
like he had objections that I didn't
fully understand that were kind of john
isms well I thought he was the one who
pushed the style rap up for well I think
part of the issue with style is that I
think it expects things that at the
front end knows natively and so in order
for me to get that to
work anatomy form as the second argument
a style I had to do some transformation
rules cuz the front-end doesn't know
what to do with a style whose second
argument is mad at me for I see I see he
wants to claim style all all for the
client side front end and that might
work right okay so let's look at this
then so wow I mean this is a complicated
structure here I mean what will be the
analogy in the Geo visualization stuff
of something like this I mean the
analogy for Geo would be you know
styling with some no well IO styling but
I mean it's the analogy for me to this
would be something that doesn't really
exist at least not in any great depth
which is where you start saying you know
what color and thickness you weren't
roads to be absolutely that's what we're
planning to have right so my question is
geo styling is let's see how does this
get done okay so geo styling why is this
not called anatomy styling then we
thought this was like an edge form or a
face form because this is more global in
other words geo styling affects the
whole scene I don't think it does no geo
styling still scopes I mean honestly I
would prefer the name Anatomy styling
because I think it's a little less now I
don't know personally I'd prefer Geo
form but
I mean we've got things like edge form
and face form neither of which are
lovely and probably would have done
better as face styling and edge styling
okay this this structure so what you're
saying is in general so what we would
imagine for Joe styling and I don't
think we have anybody here who knows
about Geo styling intrinsically but I
what we would imagine for geo styling
okay so right now these are pure let's
see should I try to grab Jose oh yeah
after you can yeah okay I mean I think
geo styling starts to get into this a
little bit with like that country
borders setting which has parameters
that allow you to say what the border
color is and what the country color is
and less about where is that not search
for country borders in scope I mean this
is are you telling you this is not
documented but it's somehow in the scope
section yes we discussed that last week
I think in a meeting with Jose and and
so it's on the list to document okay
well but then then that's probably where
we want to think about merging this okay
so country borders yeah well there we
have it
same deal really I mean it's it's
something extremely close right right
although you know still significant
differences like country borders doesn't
allow you to say that you want the u.s.
to be you know this set of properties
what do you mean I mean so this is
saying okay so this is giving the the
named sections of the country borders
thing this is I mean the question is is
the us like a metatarsal so to speak or
is it more like or are roads like a
metatarsal so to speak so actually there
now is right no what date and shall we
reform yeah it goes both ways right I
mean you can say that you know your
biceps brachii this is the style you
want or you can say this is the style I
want for muscles in general okay fine
how do you do that in anatomy form you
just put muscles in their control equals
I don't understand this crazy thing with
the rough not looking for an athlete
form is just it's just you what do you
mean it's just me how can I don't know
but it's for me yeah for me too if you
resize the notebook does it change the
effect not working weird okay um okay so
to limit you're saying anatomy form hi
this is cousin
hello we are talking about anatomy form
its relationship to geo styling
[Music]
um this is crazy this doesn't document
anything well this doesn't document that
at all so this needs to be smartened up
considerably okay yes yes and I would
have thought this should be automatic
not natural or inherited or something
what is that we had background noise
sorry I seem to be having problems with
it um cuz they are you at home or are
you in the office no no I meant the
office but there's something you were
making noises like some kind of science
fiction bad science fiction movie type
noises oh I see I'm sorry no I mean that
was happening earlier this morning also
so oh really okay yeah okay so well
let's hope now help
okay I I don't think that's the right
thing here what would be a similar
situation for like edge form what do you
do edge form of nothing draws no I mean
it's very weird to say no phases what
does that mean this documentation I
think needs a little bit of smartening
up here sure keep in mind that Anatomy
form is a modifier for things that are
already there
so when you say Anatomy form open close
if you put that in front of an entity it
means essentially you're just gonna see
the edges of the polygons making it the
model you're not going to see the
polygon faces so that could be there
aren't gonna be any edges that's right
edge for nothing it'll show nothing well
that's kind of random why are we doing
it that way why not have an atomy form
of no arguments be the thing that
restores it
because that's not what the forms do
what dowhat edge form of nothing shows
nothing is that right yes okay fair
enough
well so what's the way of getting back
to natural edge form then we don't
really have one
I mean automatic would be fine with me I
don't know that we have any other
interpretation for that do we Jeff for
what now - automatic in anatomy forms uh
not that I know I can't think of
anything okay fine all right so let's
plan on that but I think the reason we
originally did it as natural as a string
was we thought of it kind of like plot
seems and we thought we would have a
whole bunch of named Anatomy forms but
it turned out we didn't we have plot
themes and so we can problematic okay by
the way documentation point you don't
want to use Association like that you
just say an association you know like a
word like a list it's some okay this
needs to get a little lot more explicit
here okay and then you need to be able
to say that there's like either a
category so what you're telling me is if
I say this here and I say anatomy form
and then I say something like control
equals bones what is that
anatomical structures Wow is that like
gonna read in all bones somehow now it
just checks through the structure for
anything that is a bone how does it but
does it do that by when it gets the data
it's tagged with information about what
the underlying structure has annotations
buried within it so that kind of knows
what it's made up of and so we can use
that information today again and any
thing know what I should be looking for
hit green okay it's taking its time here
is that because a lot of structures and
the harm somehow quite a few other if we
have any tendons are not well okay what
didn't I do it do not do left hand and
bone it's a little bit less obscured by
muscles
well there are definitely tendons in
one's hand even I know that if we have
the models for them yeah we don't have
the models for the tendons and their
tendons are kind of weird because
they're kind of extensions of the
muscles they're kind of like the tail
into the muscles where they attack kind
of near where they attach so there's
kind of great herbs I think we have
those don't we yeah we have something
yeah there's there's the yellow things
in there now oh yeah there you go okay
fine okay what would happen if I'd said
no okay
all right um what is that if it's not I
think that's a ligament then um boy one
of these days I'm actually gonna learn
some anatomy if I wasn't too squeamish
so you can turn on was it plot theme
goes the detailed what does that
everything gets it's not gonna cat
less no but everything gets tooltips
then that's nice Wow
do we document that in a nice clear way
because that's a really good feature
I think it's mentioned in the dark
plod 3d you've probably done I mean
arguably we should even do this by
default
the only good reason to not do this by
default
it's really an extremely nice feature
not that
no of
default okay we'll turn it off on no
thumbnail or whatever right minimum all
sorts of things it's great actually
really great then I'll really learn
anatomy yes um okay the person with
handle corn-on-the-cob on our live
stream is asking if protein shapes can
be displayed in the same way it's
anatomy that is a good idea
I doubt it to the case let's see what
what can we what's a good protein
hemoglobin
how do we get a plot why wouldn't that
work then I misspelled it
No
his hemoglobin an entity I'm not sure
what that oh it says it's a protein why
wouldn't that be a reasonable
interpretation hmm what why wouldn't
that work Michael Hale on our live
stream is helpfully suggesting another
protein but I'm upset that hemoglobin
doesn't work now I don't know my my
ribbon plots well enough but what what
would be the the annotation for this we
may have the wrong set of people here to
answer that question I think you have
the wrong set of people sorry I mean I
can tell you that's an alpha helix but
that doesn't um that's yeah I'm not
quite sure how one word tooltip it but
that's an interesting idea
maybe we can would that be a John
Cassell issue Michael why don't you ask
him if he has an idea there or on or
maybe corn on the cob on our live stream
can suggest what they think should be
used for tool tipping these things and
possibly that could be also something
concerning the upcoming chemistry stuff
to forget me doing molecule objects yes
that is correct I don't know what tool
tipping is planned on the default
molecule I don't know his realization
okay let's let's loop back here okay so
the thing we're saying is that we've got
this thing geo styling which a bit like
anatomy so Anatomy form takes two kinds
of things it takes generic anatomical
well see what's really weird here is
that left hand is an anaconda anatomical
structure like nerve is an anatomical
structure the making sense whereas in
the case of of you know geo styling
we've got lakes as a generic and you
know Lake Michigan or something is a I
mean here similarly we have a specific
nerve
and then we have the generic nerves but
the point is that that Anatomy form is
letting you specify for a generic nerve
how you want it styled which is I think
what we're planning what what apparently
the country borders thing does for in
the Geo stuff right right you can
specify the generic right so what we
need is something we need the same
pattern for the anatomy form or Anatomy
styling as we do for geo styling and I
have to say I'm I'm considerably drawn
towards the idea of calling this Anatomy
styling not an anime form because I
think that that is a you know that
styling concept is you know for
something which is gonna have this
possibility okay so is it the case that
like with geo styling which your styling
we have the idea let's say we're saying
geo styling so geo styling can both be
in the know it isn't like that it's it's
both in the background Aero geo styling
type form right so if I say geo list
plot um you know Fiji or something geo
styling well then no so what I want to
do here is I want to you're saying I can
say style of Fiji is this right
it took if G of sterling will work
inside style and do you want you're less
plodding on Geographics well I guess I
can use Geographics here but I was what
I was thinking was was this would be
Fiji background Aero geo styling of
relief map for example okay but but then
what we're saying is no I don't
understand what happen there was a small
scale in the relief map isn't
interesting and why is there a an error
here
no never justified setting she's a Geo
background or background oh yes Geo
background thank you
well why does it why does it give a an
error of that type for the case of um
background if I say background shouldn't
give an error at that level right
shouldn't get through to the graphics
box
no it should really and give this kind
of error why does it knows it's wrong
long before that it's not looking at
background at all it just passes
background straight through to the
graphics underlying graphics okay this
error message is utterly obscure right I
mean that error message is that's not
the place where we should have gotten
the error message anyway I don't even
understand why background couldn't be
used to what I mean
no this that error message is crazy yes
and that's
fernand error message okay but why did
it ever get that it should have been
pruned long before it got that
there are large numbers of options that
you know the visualization functions and
you're probably even Geographics don't
so if I say graphics of disk and then I
say background Aero fish this I see
and it's definitely correct yeah what
that did is correct but why did it print
a message because you must have clicked
on the oh did I click on the on the boxy
thing yes you did all right okay okay
okay okay okay okay
I'm gonna retract my complaints there
okay okay so here so this is essentially
a bank description of Geo styling but if
I said country borders is that right
mm-hm
and then I say comma well apparently I
have to put it in a brace but I don't
really quite understand that arrow
land arrow red for example
what am I gonna get - what a bunch of
little red islands once it downloads the
polygons okay so what else could I be
saying here okay
fine
okay so the point there that this is
extremely similar to the anatomy styling
situation right where I say make the
nerves read and so on so I think there's
several things first of all we probably
want string aliases for some of the
common things like nerves and you know
for some of those collective things if
they're not a ridiculous number of them
second thing in geo styling do we want
to support something of the form
whatever I'm gonna pick a Google Google
or whatever it's some Island in Fiji is
which I wouldn't know the name of um
arrow you know you know yellow or
something like that
right so no words this is only
collective names
right but should we allow specific names
here as well as far as strings go
no not strings I'm saying I'm saying
that will be an entity a specific entity
here because that will be no I think
Jeff means you know your comment about
string nerve Oh having to use the like
if they're not all supported then we
have to document each one that is
supported this is an easy enough table
in the docs for anatomy form or whatever
we end up naming it or we could assume
that anybody that supplies a string we
assume it's an entity and construct it
for the user but then it better be an
actual entity or it's no that's fine I
think that's fine but we might as well
document a few cases but now you know
we've got an incompatibility here
because okay first of all the skull
Anatomy form
second of all doesn't this have also
some string sort of Bank versions yes
that was the quotes natural thing yeah
which we're getting rid of and we're
calling it an automatic yeah I
understand but are there other things
that Anatomy styling in other words what
is now a plot style okay next question
do we have we have plot themes for G
olace plot don't we would hope so but we
do not what style but we do not have
plot theme so we probably will have plot
theme when we allow user control of you
know I mean in other words we developed
all kinds of different stylings for maps
you know when we were originally making
our map coloring and I don't even know
is the map coloring the same between
Wolfram Alpha and the language no okay
well fine so okay so we've right there
we've got two different plot themes for
for journalist plot and so on so one
point there is will need a plot theme
the second question is we've right now
got this local styling notion which we
are supporting in geo styling which
could be globalized we could say you
know could be globalized into a plot
theme there's a bit of a muddle here am
I making sense look here's what I think
we should do I think we should consider
turning it into Anatomy styling we
should make it make both it NGO styling
consistently support both a single kind
of Bank switch thing so it would be you
know anatomy styling and then well okay
hold on
so then you know something that says I
don't know whatever you want to call it
um let's say scientific although that's
not really the kind of terminology I'm
I'm talking about and then it would be I
guess nerve arrow red or something
something like this or possibly we don't
have that but then geo styling right now
Joe styling we are supporting this one
weird case with country borders why
isn't this autocomplete in hello why
isn't that autocomplete in no I think
we've lost Jose that's a shame
okay so right now this is lista fide to
give it to give its parameters here but
maybe we should do it like this
consistently with Anatomy styling if we
have an Anatomy styling so just for
clarification what does the scientific
first argument mean it's a set of
defaults I say similar to the plot style
in other words this is a combination a
plot theme with a specified override of
nerve goes to red I'm sorry say that
again I was gonna say I mean I think the
plot themes are specifying you know sets
of colors and I don't remember if Tim is
giving you you know the big association
up front or if you've got something on
the back end
[Music]
but you know like the muscles are all
different shades of red depending on the
theme and that's coming from somewhere
right and so this would be that plus an
override right which is because in the
case of Geo styling there's
parameterization of country borders
because it has certain components that
can be colored now that's a little
different because in the Anatomy case
where I mean on the face of it it's the
same components always but I suspect
that's also true a Geo styling you know
there are Lakes whatever it however
you're rendering it whether it's with
you know relief plots or whether it's
with borders or whatever they're still
lakes I'm not certain about that because
in something like the street map thing
we actually have the streets to render
in the tiles
whereas if we're doing relief plot we
don't have streets as such um okay look
main conclusion is I think what we need
to do I'm really pushing this Anatomy
styling idea an analogy to geo styling
um I don't have a major objection to
renaming it the structural form we'll
have to look into see how hard that is
to implement I don't doubt it can be
done but it might require some
overhauling that could be non-trivial
I'm not sure okay
well why don't we look at that and we're
still not the experimental icing and
thank goodness it is experimental
because we won't change it a bit and
let's see how we merge it with the with
the geo styling idea um so for 12 we
won't be D experimenting yet or just not
for now not for now I mean if we happen
to get it in time great but I think we
should leave it okay until we get that
figured out yeah hopefully this is not a
long term thing to get it figured out
it may not be I have to look at it right
I'm really keen on the Geo styling the
finer control of Geo styling and
unfortunately it seems like Hosea is not
here so we can't really discuss that in
more detail um and I guess it's
anatomical skin style although the truth
is that this geo styling thing I mean
that's really a you know a courtesy
switch for something in geo styling
the fact is geo styling should really
give um the UM you know what I'm saying
not quite um okay so what I'm saying is
just like you can say nerve arrow read
you should be able to say skin arrow
opacity whatever it is right in other
words the skin is one of the components
of the anatomy styling isn't it yes
right normally you can do that with just
the Association now it's just that first
argument that isn't supported fair
enough but I mean the you're saying
anatomical skin style is basically a
courtesy switch equivalent to yeah yeah
don't specify skin style is it pulling
down the data to start with skin style
pulls the skin end for you automatically
otherwise if you don't specify skin in
the first argument you're not gonna have
the skin Anatomy sailing we'll ignore
that unless you've told it to include
the skin fine but right so what we're
saying is that by default in all of
these typical styles and we could change
that for some of them by default you
know the skin isn't included I mean we
might have an Anatomy styling which says
you know exterior or something which is
full opacity skin and it might choose to
do the optimization of not pulling the
data down if some component is simply
not there if the nerves are specifying
as specified I mean in this what we want
to say is you know something like nerve
arrow none if we just don't want you
know don't render the bones will be more
like that I would think and then there's
the optimization of don't pull down the
data if the styling is none
hmm because that's equivalent to what
you're doing with skin I'm just
generalizing well the anatomy form never
anatomy style never pulls down anything
it the code doesn't even look at Anatomy
no III understand I'm suggesting that in
sort of a glorious feature there's an
optimization that could be done but you
don't have to do that right will the
date sit down and then just choose not
to render it if you want to write um I
need to go on and we have things to work
on so yeah we didn't get to the second
section of this meeting um that was
rescheduled to 3:30 today okay great so
um just to confirm
we'll keep it experimental unless we get
to rename it as an anatomy styling and
if if we do need some yeah and the
documentation needs to be spruced up
with it yep from where am i storing do I
need to store this file did I do
anything of interest here or just whose
p.m. in here there is no p.m. for
anatomy so I'm I have the notes yeah
okay you want me to send this to
somebody
oh yeah send it to me Jeff and Michael
and Raj okay I'm just gonna send you
those lines because I think that's the
only thing we did that was a really
interest yeah all right okay all right
see y'all soon and for those on this
live stream we will be returning for
another episode at when is it one hour
from now um oh that's a different thing
okay okay Gilson all right I